Hello world.
It's Saroj and it seems like these
days everybody is creating some kind of
cryptocurrency token for their business
or research or even just for fun.
Pot coined sponsored a celebrity's
trip to North Korea. What the fuck?
In this video,
I'll show you how you can make your
own token using the etherium platform.
When bitcoin launched in 2009 as
the world's first cryptocurrency,
it had the single goal of allowing for
value transfer without the need for a
middleman.
Bitcoin's blockchain data structure is
essentially a worldwide excel spreadsheet
that is formed by lots of
computers talking to each other.
This blockchain is a digital ledger
continuously recording and verifying
records. It's used to track and
verify bitcoin transactions.
Etherium is also a public blockchain
network and its appeal is that it has its
own Turing complete scripting language
that lets developers build what are
called smart contracts.
Smart contracts are strings of computer
code capable of automatically executing
when certain predetermined
conditions are met.
Instead of requiring a single
central authority to say Yay or Nay,
these contracts are self operated. For
example, a smart contract could say,
pay Joe $10 every time he watches Oprah
speech and cries and it would pay Joe
once those conditions are met
because all the nodes run this code,
etherium can be considered a worldwide
computer that no one can turn off and
that no one can tamper with.
It runs exactly as programmed.
It's like using a service like Amazon
or digital ocean to upload programs and
run them, except there isn't a single
party behind it. Sorry, not sorry,
Mr Bayzos.
Ether is the cryptocurrency that powers
this network by allowing users to pay
for smart contract transaction fees.
So one type of smart contract
that's gotten really popular
recently is the token
smart contract tokens or digital assets
that can represent anything from loyalty
points to vouchers to IOUs,
to securities to actual
physical objects like vibrators.
A token is nothing more than a smart
contract running on top of the etherium
blockchain. It's a set of functions
with an associated database.
The code describes the behavior of the
token and the database is just a table of
rows and columns tracking
who owns how many tokens.
If a user or another smart contract in
etherium sends a message to that tokens
contract in the form of the transaction,
the code updates it's database,
so let's say a wallet APP sends a message
to a tokens contract to transfer funds
from Joe to Jack the tokens contract.
We'll first check that the message was
signed by Joe and that he has sufficient
funds to cover the payment.
Then it moves the funds from Joe's
account to Jack's account in the database.
It will then send a response
letting the wallet, no,
that transaction was a success in order
to create a user friendly and broadly
accessible system per token creation.
A set of standards called Erc 20 was
created by the etherium developers.
Erc 20 defines a set of six functions
that other smart contracts within the
etherium ecosystem will
understand and recognize.
These include for instance,
how to transfer a token by the owner or
on behalf of the owner and how to access
data like name, symbol, supply
and balance about the token.
Together these functions and events make
etherium tokens work the same almost
everywhere within the etherium ecosystem.
This interoperability is important
to spur an ecosystem. As a result,
nearly all wallets that support ether
now also support Erc 20 compliant tokens,
so let's create a standard Erc 20 token.
A set amount will be created and we
won't have any fancy rules like finance
skynet to with all the profits.
The first step is to decide what we want
our token to be. We'll decide a name,
symbol, number of decimal places, and
the number of tokens in circulation.
Most tokens have 18 decimal places.
Let's keep it simple.
We want people to either have a
token or not, nothing in between,
so we'll choose zero. Our next step is
to actually code this token contract.
Luckily for us,
we can just copy and paste a standard
Erc 20 token template contract written in
solidity etherium scripting language.
It's a token contract with functions
that defined the total amount of tokens
balance.
The act of transferring funds
and approving transactions
will inherit from the
initial token class. To add the details
of how our specific token will work.
Using custom variables,
we can replace the filler words with the
values we find to be best in our text
editor.
The supply we set for our
token is correlated to the
amount of decimal places we
set. So if we had a token with zero
decimal places and a hundred tokens,
then the supply would be a hundred but
if we had 18 decimal places and a hundred
tokens, then the supply would
be a much bigger number.
We also set the amount of tokens we
receive as a creator of the contract.
For now, we'll just set it equal to the
supply. So we receive all the tokens.
We could set it with different rules,
so different founders of our project
could receive different amounts,
but we're going lone wolf right now.
All right,
now we'll deploy this token to the
etherium test net just to see if it works.
We can download metta mask since it has
an easy to use interface to test this
out. Once installed, we'll set
up the rops, didn't test network.
Then we'll head to the
solidity remix compiler,
which is an online compiler that
publishes smart contracts straight to the
blockchain.
We can copy and paste the source code
of our contract into the main window.
We can go to the setting and select
the latest release compiler version and
uncheck enable optimization.
We'll go back to the
contract tab and hit create.
Under the name of the token function.
We create Mehta mask will then pop up
asking us to hit submit to pay for the
transaction. Of course we
will. It's not real ether.
It's a test net and when we hit submit
it'll say contract pending in metal mask.
When we click the date, it'll bring up
a screen that details the transaction.
Now we can see if it actually created
the tokens and sent them to our wallet.
We'll copy the contract address and
add it to the Metta Mask Tokens Tab.
It says we have a hundred tokens,
so it worked.
Now we can send those tokens or sell
them on a market if we decide to.
We can also create another contract
that automatically sends these tokens of
people.
If they send us a certain amount of ether,
which could power your
next ICO like Jesus coin.
We'll also want to verify the source
code so that the public knows we're not
doing anything shady.
We can deploy our token to the main
net so people can actually use it.
So we'll basically do the
same thing we just did,
except instead of being connected to the
rob test network will be connected to
the main net. Will need to fund our
contract with real ether. To do this,
it can cost anywhere from 20 to $50
worth of ether. As of now is summarize.
A token is a digital asset that can
represent anything from loyalty points to
vouchers to securities.
Tokens are smart contracts and we can
easily create them using the etherium
blockchains, Turing complete
scripting language called solidity.
And to create a token,
we just fill in a smart contract template
written in solidity with our details
and deploy it to the theory and
blockchain the a tool called Metta mask.
Please subscribe for more
programming videos. And for now,
I've got a great Suraj Goin,
so thanks for watching.